the people have spoken we might get
Babylon 5 reboot a little quicker than
we were hoping welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of days ago the Babylon 5
Creator John M josinski or JMS because
that's much easier to say as I say in
every video
went on Twitter and he asked the Babylon
5 fans to get on to his hashtag I'll put
it here for you and he got babylon5
trending on Twitter almost immediately
now he then released a statement just
earlier today saying loud and clear you
were heard thank you so so much now this
is hinting that maybe he has spoken to
somebody at the CW at Warner Brothers
they have been impressed by this
slightly risky tactic from JMS and that
that might just help our course in
wanting to get Babylon 5 back in our
screens so I got in touch with a few
people and I know uh that I know work in
the industry and ask them what they
thought oh by the way if you do like the
content please consider hitting the join
button and becoming a fully fledged side
tracker you can also go to side
track.com and pick marvelous merchandise
all of these little things really help
the channel also if you're new to the
channel like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and share the video
whatever the hell you want well the one
person's got back to me so far has said
that
it was a very risky tactic of JMS it was
a thought through though considered risk
he knows that Warner Brothers and the CW
are in conversations about Babylon 5. he
knows and he was one that told me the
Warner Brothers would actually like
Babylon 5 to go on to HBO Max they don't
want to go on CW they just don't want it
and they're really pushing for that now
JMS seems to be pushing for it to go on
the CW his hashtag actually said Babylon
5 on the CW in 2023
I said it was shorter than that but you
know what to me
so he's pushing for the CW Now I asked
this person I speak to why the hell is
he pushing for the CW that makes no
sense
hbr Max have been pushing to get this on
there for three or four months at least
and he said well he doesn't actually
understand that himself except for the
fact that JMS actually is really loyal
but also he's a little bit old school
and he believes he's pushing for it to
go on to the CW because it is a network
there's no paywall you obviously have to
subscribe to HBO Max you don't have to
go to the CW so more people get to see
it this way and it's what the fans want
so that's why he's pushing for it and is
one of the reasons why he did the
hashtag because he wanted to reinforce
that what is the position with Warner
Brothers and HBO Max because I say I've
done a couple of videos before saying
that actually this might go on to HBO
Max first
while nothing has really changed just
yet Warner Brothers is apparently still
pushing for HBO Max this would be quite
a big project for them they've had
really good views on the original B5
series actually that's on HBO Max right
now so they would be more than happy to
get the rebooted series as well they
think it would be really good and
there's a really loyal fan base of
Babylon 5 views out there the Twitter
immediate trending shows that
and a real appetite for this series they
love it on HBO Max but the CW does
actually have the ball in their court on
this one they were the ones that
approached Amos to do this they're the
ones that have the um a ridge this
descript for the um for the for the
pilot so they do have control on this my
sources have always been on the
assumption that actually Warner Brothers
would get their way because they don't
because they didn't think the CWA wanted
this type of content on the channel
anymore that's all the noise coming at
CWS is this is not the sort of thing
they want to do and but also that they
just wouldn't want to sour the
relationship with Warner Brothers this
early on
so that it would end up on HBO Max
if it does end up on a CW it'll be
basically because of JMS and in part
because of the Twitter feed that's
happened and the the Twitter storm that
really followed James's request
so that's where we're at right now
I did ask have there been any meetings
do you know if there's anything that's
happened today
um he says that that there's nothing
that he knows about for certain but the
whispers are that this is going to
happen he says it is almost certain that
they're going to make this they're in a
negotiation circle at the moment as I
say Warner Brothers would really like
this in HBO max they're trying to get
the CW to Let It Go
they might not work they're also
wrangling over budgets because basically
what JMS would like to do is an old
school 22 episode series but everyone
else would just like him to do sort of
like the more what we get nowadays 10 or
12 episodes so all of those
conversations apparently are happening
but those are all just rumors going
around the industry
now I'm going to be following this video
up with another video and I'm going to
talk about what do I think Babylon 5
will look like in the coming series now
JMS has already said a few times on
Twitter that if if that somebody
suggests something in a video like this
then he won't be able to do it so I'm
not I don't want to really talk about
specific storylines
but JMS really does have a difficult
situation in this hand so I will in the
next video remind you what he's already
said about this and then talk to you a
little bit about the stumbling blocks
he's going to face and where I think he
should generally take the story and I've
been asking you over the last 24 hours
where you would take the story I'll
share that too
so if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content don't forget to
become a fully fledged side tracker and
hit the join button because that really
supports the channel as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]